we have the leader of the open section
Fabiano caruana with us Fabi another
draw another step towards the
championship you're going into the final
round with a half a point lead how do
you feel right now
yeah today was good I was under a lot of
pressure
um the opening didn't really go the way
I wanted
so and then the draw was a good result
and there was also good that Ray didn't
didn't catch up
were you worried that Christopher is
going to play a loose game given his
past results yeah he sometimes plays
very well and sometimes very uh
carelessly so today he played a very
whiskey line but uh I mean it's supposed
to be a bit dubious for white this line
it's very tricky because the black can
lose by force but I mean once I saw like
the time and he Christopher was playing
so quickly and seemed to know the
position well I I didn't feel like um
like he would lose that game I even
thought that maybe
I mean if anyone's going to win it's
more likely to be Christopher after the
opening uh so yeah overall it was a good
day uh I don't know if Sam is like at
this game I just can't comprehend sounds
seems to be a bit worse at this point
this is what we have right now yeah I
just don't understand this position I
mean
you'd rather be black yes
but I don't know what's going on I I
mean it's it's strange to say black is
like white is worse I mean it's either a
draw or it's winning for black yeah uh
which I I would assume it's a draw
usually these things turn into a draw
but
um or maybe not
we don't know I mean you have to be very
I mean that King is in a rather
precarious position position on the
other hand he is two Rooks aren't going
to make the King Alone
uh he's winning H7 I don't know but uh
as long as he doesn't win it's uh it's
kind of okay for me absolutely I don't
think he'll win and you mentioned that
you were under some pressure out of the
opening it felt that way as well with
your opening Choice were you trying to
keep some chances alive in case
Christopher is is not he's playing loose
well not really I mean I I wanted to
keep chances alive but uh you know
getting the worst position from the
opening is not really the way to do it
um I just
played a lot I'm not super familiar with
I've used to play a long time ago but I
just thought like I played Knight C7
recently and I didn't expect this choice
no no after instead of G6 the other main
line is Knight C7
and I played it recently and I thought
maybe he'll be ready for this so I
decided okay I'll just play G6 I tried
to remember my decision over the board
this was my Kansas preparation from
2016. yeah it was over the border and
trying to remember
but failing to I remember I played
against Peter swedler here and he played
Knight G5 E6 D3
I played I think Bishop G7 he played a
H4
or the first night by G4 and then uh was
it like played B6 or Castle I don't
remember
B6 stage for something like the b6h4
yeah
I was losing this game I mean he came
this was a brilliant idea at the time
um from what I understand computers just
say it's a complete uh nonsense now but
at the time it was yeah it was based on
this exchange stock which uh like white
takes on C5 and after I remove H5 or H I
don't remember exactly and then white
takes on C5 take everything
these type of positions yeah I think it
was this maybe not with agency
yeah it was probably with H6
um and here I couldn't I mean Bishop G7
I was trying to remember because there's
like this move Queen C4 and I couldn't
figure it out yeah my db4 castle I was
like okay I'm gonna lose upon it I'm
going to regret this decision I played
the more solid move instead E6
kind of just accepting a slightly worse
position
but at least I'm solid I guess
but I wasn't happy I mean his moves are
so easy here he just everything he did
it's just so so natural Rook D1 King F1
and I played this move F5 I don't know I
was a bit worried about it but I didn't
see what else to do and I thought this
is kind of forcing his hand he can play
A3 he can take on D5 but he you'll want
to do something because I might at some
some stage want to play at four I mean
he has to make a move I thought E3 is
also moved but then my db4 is probably
I'm sorry a night I'd see before uh
Queen D7 Rook D7 and I thought this
equalizes
you have some problems with these yeah
some problems with A2 as well probably
not A2 but D3 is very difficult I mean
he'll he might have to play an id5
Knight D5 and then V2 is hanging so he's
unlikely to get an advantage here uh and
so I was actually a bit surprised after
A3 94 I was expecting Queen C4
I wasn't sure what this was Queen C4
it's like yeah F4 I wanted but I wasn't
sure gf4 because if I take twice then E3
yeah this I this I like it was too
chaotic for me to understand but I also
understand why he didn't go for it so if
you take Queen F7 is that the idea I
guess I guess so
I mean it's very risky of course to us
but but I really thought he would want
to win today
so I was kind of expecting a sharper
choice because Queen D5 had Queen E7 I
didn't feel like
like I should be really worse I mean
tiny bit but and I think you guys enter
this very forced line
which the computer by the way was
recommending all these moves but it
doesn't seem like it worse yeah if he
doesn't play Bishop before I thought I
might be better
like I don't know some of Bishop E1 and
I play like King F7 okay he always has
Bishop B4 I guess but
um but if he doesn't at some point play
this move then I'll play Rook B6 King E6
maybe at some stage because I always
have this Knight D2 trick which uh if I
can get King E6 and Rook B7 then 92
becomes a thread and his Rooks are stuck
so that's why he played Bishop V4 and
then I still thought I'm
rather like slightly unpleasantly worse
great yeah it's a bit unpleasant
for example at this moment like I
thought rupee 5 was kind of clever if I
if I play another move for example
I play rookie six it was my first
attention he takes takes Rook C1 I
didn't see how to completely equalize
this position like A4 Rook
um
Rook C6
Rook D6 Rook C8
Rook A6 and Rook G and I I thought this
was unpleasant still a complicated
position but after Bishop to F3 it
seemed like you guys uh went into a
drawish line yeah Bobby we'll let you go
get your rest and we'll see you tomorrow
in the championship round
indeed good luck Fabi